alemania aprobó el mayor gasto para el
departamento de defensa en los últimos
83 años esto supone el mayor cambio de
seguridad del país desde la segunda
guerra mundial el parlamento alemán
acordó modificar la constitución y crear
un fondo de 100 mil millones de euros
para así modernizar su ejército además
comenzará a destinar más del 2 por
ciento de su pib a la defensa el fondo
se va a repartir a lo largo de cinco
años y servirá para incrementar el gasto
anual en defensa a alemania desde los 50
mil millones de euros de euros actuales
hasta los 70 mil millones de euros por
año
con esta decisión alemania entonces se
convertiría en el mayor potencia militar
de europa y la tercera más grande del
mundo detrás de china y eeuu antes de la
invasión a rusia ucrania
esta postura habría sido casi que
inaceptable pero en los últimos meses
los políticos alemanes empezaron a darse
cuenta de que el ejército no atraviesa
su mejor momento además gran parte de
los equipos están obsoletos o mal
mantenidos salvamos entonces a nuestro
segundo invitado del día él es isidro
sepúlveda analista internacional y
especialista en geopolítica grasa isidro
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
francia 24 empecemos entonces por el
significado que tiene este giro
histórico para alemania
el significado que realmente es
trascendente y está lo más importante de
todo es que no es un giro puntual ni un
giro aislado de un país sino que está
dentro de un contexto de replanteamiento
de toda la política exterior de toda la
política internacional de seguridad que
está aconteciendo en europa en los
últimos meses a consecuencia de la
agresión la invasión de rusia sobre
ucrania alemania hay que hacer una
mínima labor pedagógica alemania sale de
la segunda guerra mundial no solamente
sin ejércitos sino militarmente ocupadas
por tres o tres potencias
hasta el año 55 como tal no no tiene no
tiene ejército
y su desarrollo siempre fue muy muy
pequeño y muy ligado a las necesidades
de complementariedad de las fuerzas
estadounidenses en el territorio alemán
después de la unificación las hubo en
realidad más disfunciones que agregados
entre las dos alemanias
no va a ser ya hasta el siglo 21 cuando
alemania a través precisamente también
de una reforma constitucional comience a
participar en misiones militares en el
exterior es decir la defensa en alemania
está muy caracterizada fundamentalmente
por lo vivido anteriormente ha habido un
recorte una contención en la
capitalización en la inversión en
defensa en alemania no en los últimos
años sino en las últimas prácticamente
siete décadas y si quiero conectarme
cuál sería la reacción que puede tener
moscú como pudiera actuar moscú ante lo
que pudiera calificar también como una
nueva amenaza
bueno en realidad
más que una amenaza lo que vas a
encontrar se es un enorme obstáculo
alemania ha tenido una
fuerza militar
bastante digna y un poco desarrollada
con inversiones importantes pero muy
lejos de su nivel tanto industrial como
demográfico en europa lo que va a
ocurrir es que va a convertirse en una
fuerza militar de enorme magnitud y
desde luego la primera en el continente
europeo al menos en la parte continental
sin antes haber dicho que se va a
convertir en la tercera en realidad va a
ser más bien en la cuarta gran bretaña
todavía va a estar un poco por delante a
no ser que esto se mantenga en los
próximos lustros en cinco años esto nos
da un cambio muy importante pero
realmente lo trascendente frente a moscú
sobre todo es la emergencia de una
defensa europea capitana apt nada ya
también desde una forma decidida por
alemania
puede
responder a las agresiones rusas y la
capacidad de retorsión de rusia en
realidad se está reduciendo de una forma
abismal ahora ya prácticamente solamente
pueden chantajear con el recorte del gas
pero militarmente rusia ya no da mucho
más de sí si no puede invertir más está
invirtiendo muy por encima de sus
posibilidades y buena parte de estas
capacidades se están quemando en en
ucrania también como si usted decidiera
no hay que olvidar esta crisis
energética y económica derivada de la
guerra de la guerra en ucraniano
entonces de dónde va a sacar estos
recursos alemania para poder paliar y
pues financiar esta iniciativa
los recursos
energéticos
los recursos económicos los recursos
económicos los sacan de su economía
alemania es con mucho la economía más
son más fuerte y más sólida de todas de
toda europa precisamente por su demanda
industrial es víctima del chantaje
energético que le hacemos precisamente
por eso ha comenzado a afirmar una ronda
de contratos fundamentalmente con
argelia y con algunos de los
emiratos del golfo pérsico para
garantizar un suministro eléctrico pero
que desde luego se tiene que se tiene
que garantizar por vías complementarias
no no no puede haber una super
producción tanto de argelia como de de
los emiratos para suministrar toda la
energía que europa recibía a través de
los gasoductos y oleoductos rusos en
todo caso el cambio afecta repito es que
afecta no solamente a un presupuesto de
defensa de un país sino que le afecta no
solamente a los presupuestos sino a la
concepción de la defensa de estos países
de europa y desde luego va a tener una
gran repercusión en la política exterior
y en los planteamientos de la seguridad
internacional europea y si durante esta
decisión de alemania podemos ver en más
países europeos o sino también en países
de la región que se sumen digamos a esta
iniciativa de rearmar y configurar su
armamento y su ejército en realidad
todos lo están haciendo todos los países
están subiendo su presupuesto de defensa
durante décadas no en los últimos años
sino durante décadas todos los
presidentes de eeuu que pasaron por las
cumbres de la otan solicitaron a los
presidentes a los los dirigentes
europeos que incrementarán su
presupuesto de defensa hasta alcanzar el
2 por ciento y esto es de todas estas
cumbres decían que si lo harían pero
ninguno lo hacía ni siquiera francia que
tenía una enorme autonomía militar y
exclusivamente gran bretaña
superaba muy ligeramente el dos por
ciento ahora todos los países están
modificando sus presupuestos de defensa
para alcanzar el 2 por ciento del pib
incluso
va a llegar a dos y medio y va a subir
un punto porcentual en relación a su pib
en el año 20 que son las últimas cifras
alemania se situaba
inmediatamente después de gran bretaña y
un poco por delante en inversión
absoluta de francia pero muy por debajo
de ambas potencias en relación al número
de esos habitantes y por tanto tiene
todavía una gran capacidad de
crecimiento la gran duda es si esto se
va a mantener el tiempo o solamente lo
aprobado este gasto extra de 100 mil
millones de euros queda para cinco años
si una vez que se agote lo van a lo van
a mantener si esto es así alemania sí
que se va a convertir en una de las
grandes potencias militares incluso
solamente alemania por encima por
delante de de la rebelde federación rusa